in this video we're going to try to
compute 6740 2 times 23 so like always
pause this video and try to compute it
for yourself
alright now let's work on this together
and I'm going to do it using what's
often known as the standard algorithm
algorithms just a fancy word for a a
series of steps a process for doing
something so we have six thousand seven
hundred forty two times 23 and so I'm
gonna write the twenty three in the same
place values so that's 210 so I'm gonna
write it under the for tens over there
and then three ones I'll write it under
the two ones and it's important to
realize this isn't the only way to
multiply numbers in fact we've studied
other methods for doing it in other
videos and it's important to realize
what's really going on and how these
different methods are all on some level
doing the same thing maybe just writing
them different or doing them in
different orders so the way that we
would tackle it using the standard
algorithm probably the way that you're
your parents first learned to multiply
multi digit numbers like this is we'll
take all of the numbers in 6740 to all
of the various places and multiply it by
three and then we're going to multiply
it times two tens and then we're gonna
add everything up
so let's first multiply it times three
so we have 2 times 3 that is 6 then we
have 4 times 3 and what people often say
is 4 times 3 is 12
write the 2 and then carry the 1 but
what really just happened is you said 4
tens times 3 is 12 tens 12 tens can be
written as two tens plus 100 then we say
seven times three is 21 and then you'll
say oh I have to add that other one so I
get 22 but once again what just happened
we said seven hundreds times 3 is 21
hundred plus another hundred is 22
hundreds which can be expressed as two
hundred and two thousands and then last
but not least 6 times 3 is 18 plus two
is 20 but remember we're talking about
thousands so this is 20 thousands so
then we will move on to the two tens
right over here so two times two tens
is for tens now some folks might be
tempted to put the four over there but
that's not for tens for tens would be
right over here and so it's common
practice as you move to the next place
value over as you get to this to that
people will just put a zero here just so
they don't make that mistake all right
now let's keep going
what is 4 times 2 well that's 8 will
just write the 8 right over there why
did that work well we're having four
tens times two tens well that's going to
be 8 times 10 times 10 eight hundreds
and then we say what is seven times 2
that is 14 which of course we can write
the 4 and then we can carry the 1 so to
speak and I'll cross these out so I
don't get confused and then 6 times 2 is
going to be equal to 12
Plus this one that we had carried is 13
so there we go and then we just have to
add everything up and we are going to
get 6 plus 0 ones is 6 2 tens plus four
tens is 6 tens to hundreds plus eight
hundreds is 10 hundreds which could you
as 0 hundreds and 1000 1000 plus 0
thousands plus 4 thousands is 5
thousands to 10 thousands plus 3 10
thousands is going to be 5 10 thousands
and then we just have 100,000 right over
there so we've got 155 thousand and 66
and we are done